Trump for his part is looking great
Trump yesterday went to East Palestine
Ohio the Buddha judge hasn't been there
Joe Biden hasn't been there Joe Biden's
been too busy paddling around with his
buddy Vladimir zielinski and Kiev so he
hasn't had time to go visit his own
citizens in Ohio after a trained
derailment poisoned the air and the
water in that town that's that's flyover
country Biden's not going to make it
there so Trump shows up and Trump
makes a few different stops in the town
one of which my favorite of which is in
a McDonald's
hello everybody that's a nice beautiful
looking beautiful baby
so I know this menu better than you do
okay I probably know it better than
anybody in here why are you visiting
today well we brought a lot of people
with us and more importantly we brought
the Federal
as uh when they heard I was coming they
all came they weren't going to come they
were going to leave you abandoned and
now they're not uh the owner over here
he saw that I helped out all the
responders and everything the first week
I was out here making Egg McMuffins
myself Saturday morning you did a good
with these guys he did a good job so
give us a nice array of stuff take care
of the people and I'll see you later
okay
can I get a picture with you
this is
vintage perfect Trump this is the best
version of trump
when Trump shows up to a McDonald's and
he says listen great to be with you all
I love being here I know this menu
better than you workers do
that's a great moment because it's
believable it's sincere the guy actually
loves McDonald's something that people
really like about Trump a lot of the
Republican establishment never
understood this they say how is it that
these working-class people like this
billionaire who was born into wealth and
who's been a Playboy Billionaire's whole
life
because Donald Trump's tastes
are the tastes of regular people
Donald Trump's comportment
behavior is the behavior of Regular
People Donald Trump's priorities or the
priorities of regular people that's why
yes he was born into a lot of wealth the
man actually loves McDonald's and
probably knows the McDonald's menu
better than most of the workers of that
franchise
yes Donald Trump was born into wealth
and into High Society but
for one he wasn't exactly accepted by
the elite Society in New York but even
beyond that his priorities his
affections his political vision is much
closer to the political vision of
blue-collar workers in the Rust Belt
than it is to some guy working at a
think tank in Washington DC you see that
on trade you see that on immigration you
see that on national identity you see
that on everything okay so if if Joe
Biden showed up here said I'll have a
give me a triple double large Mac please
you wouldn't believe you just think Joe
Biden this guy doesn't go to McDonald's
but Trump shows up he goes hey everybody
we're gonna have a great meal at
McDonald's that it it it brings you
something
in the political scene That You Don't
See very much which is it's not just
some policy it's not just some photo op
it's it's thumos it's spiritedness it's
a it's a a sense that this guy
this guy's very essence share is a kind
of similarity to his constituents and
that is a very very powerful in politics
Donald Trump did not show up to East
Palestine empty-handed
Donald Trump also gave a big rally and
he brought a lot of supplies and he
brought a lot of water as he explained
in great detail
especially thank some of the incredible
people that helped us because we're
bringing thousands of bottle of water
Trump water actually most of it uh some
of it we had to go to a much lesser
Quality Water
you want to get those Trump bottles I
think more than anybody else but we're
bringing a lot of water
love it this again
the Liberals just don't know how to
interpret this there were liberals
freaking out on social media they said
Donald Trump he's there Shilling his
water how Shameless is he he's trying no
he's not he's not selling his water he's
not selling it to the citizens of East
Palestine I don't think he sells it
period I don't think you can go to a
grocery store and buy Trump water
why is he talking about Trump water I'm
sure that's just the water he picked up
at his hotels and golf clubs and
Mar-A-Lago
so he happens to have that water and he
loaded it on but it wasn't enough
compared to what they wanted to bring so
they brought some other water too and
then Trump goes in
and he makes a joke about it
and it's funny and everybody gets the
joke except for the humorless elite
liberals who are still plotting out like
Wiley Coyote had to drop the next piano
on his head until the Road Runner runs
away too fast
look we got we brought a lot of water
brought a lot of trump water actually
that's the water you want to get that's
the good one we brought some much lesser
Quality Water that's still the water
that he brought very generously donated
to East Palestine but he's just
I I was really really gratified to see
this in East Palestine one because he
actually is calling attention to it when
they say what else did you bring he said
I brought the federal government is what
I brought because no one was paying
attention to this and then I'm showing
up and now Biden has to show up which is
good and and that's something that Trump
has brought to politics ever since he
came down that golden escalator so I'm
glad to see that the other thing I'm
glad to see is it feels like he's kind
of getting his mojo back
he at his announcement at Mar-A-Lago it
was kind of weak sauce some of the
appearances he's been making recently
have been just kind of
Bland they haven't had that Trump magic
but this was a really great this was a
really great political event it was good
for the citizens it was good for Trump's
campaign it it presented him as himself
as this American original
he's the guy who's going to show up and
donate a lot of supplies because he's
got a lot of money he's got more money
than most of the candidates in the race
at least maybe all of them
he's gonna he's gonna tell some jokes
he's gonna lift some people's spirits
and he's going to seem
paradoxically like one of them
there is not one candidate in the GOP
field who likes McDonald's more than
Donald Trump and that is a powerful
political tool it seems trivial but
that's a powerful political tool
speaking of speaking of the
water around East Palestine
a grocery chain has pulled water that
happens to be bottled near East
Palestine and you might say why are they
doing that Michael we've been told by
all the officials that the water is
totally fine remember the EPA
administrator comes in and says that
water around East Palestine you know
where they just dumped a gazillion
gallons of chemicals that are extremely
toxic and some of which were used as
poison gases in World War one yeah no
it's fine drink the water you're all
good
now what happens JD Vance the Republican
senator shows up
he's looking at some water he throws a
rock in a creek and then everything
looks like an oily rainbow
there are clearly so many chemicals in
the water
so this grocery store chain Giant Eagle
is pulling from its shelves bottled
water sourced from a facility near East
Palestine Ohio they say out of an
abundance of caution
Giant Eagle has made the decision to
remove all gallon size or greater Giant
Eagle brand Spring Water Products
sourced from salineville facility
that's right near East Palestine until
further notice until we continue to
evaluate ongoing testing and potential
impacts to the spring source
the water is obviously poisoned this is
not out of an abundance of caution this
is out of the very bare minimum of
caution of course people don't want to
buy it
the grocery store chain doesn't want to
be on the hook if people get poisoned
from this stuff so they're pulling it
absolutely right yes this contradicts
what we've been told by the EPA
administrator but look at people's
behavior
people's behavior is going to tell you
very often a lot more than their words
are
all the liberal politicians say the
water's totally safe the air is totally
safe but they're not going to show up
are they haven't made it there yet to
East Palestine they haven't breathed
that air in the two weeks after the the
crash three weeks now
they haven't had that water to drink the
Ohio Senator the Democrat Ohio Senator
was interviewed on TV
and he was asked Sherrod Brown will you
and the other officials in this town
drink the water he evaded the question
no they're not going to drink the water
they think it's poison they might tell
you they don't think that but look at
their behavior
they might tell you it's not poison
we'll look at the behavior of the
grocery store what does that tell you it
means you can't take what these people
say at face value you've got to conduct
your own research the rest of the show
continues now we'll be chatting with you
in our Circle remember block go to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
to check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]